[Music]
the loud house is now the most popular
kids animated show on Nickelodeon if you
are a fan you have probably watched all
the episodes but there are still many
things that you do not know just wait
until you see my mother's started a
petition against the sitcom after Luna
did something they thought was
inappropriate if you love the loud house
as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
10 dark secrets in the loud house
Nickelodeon tried to hide the gay couple
and one of the episodes of the sitcom
overnight success we discovered that
Clyde had two fathers of different
colors Harold and Howard it was the
first Nickelodeon show in history to
feature
unmarried same-sex couples and just
because we love diversity we were happy
to see that one of them was white and
the other was black and it didn't make
any difference however many people
didn't agree that it was a good idea to
represent the LGBTQ community in a kids
show 1 Million Moms is probably the
group that reacted the most to this when
they heard that the creators of the loud
house wanted to feature a family with
two dads on the animated show they
immediately took action
they said that Nickelodeon should stick
to entertain instead of pushing an
agenda and provide a family-friendly
programming instead of being politically
correct and we think that the channel
should actually be family-friendly but
the best way to do it is by showing a
lot of different families including gay
couples it doesn't make the show less
entertaining and it also gives a chance
to some kids to be more comfortable
talking about their two dads the only
thing that will happen is that they will
learn that love is love we think the
characters of the loud house made a
great decision by giving us the chance
to meet these two funny dads in this
episode the rabbits did you know that
the characters of the loud house used to
be a big family of rabbits this is one
of the ideas that the creator Chris
Savino presented to the producers Chris
that it was a funny idea because rabbits
multiply however it was just chaotic to
work with so many different animal
characters producers loved the big
family but Jenna Boyd's the executive
and development suggested that he should
work on humans instead because he would
have more chances to get it sold Chris
really wanted to work on animals but the
more he thought about it the more he
realized that a family of humans was the
right way to go this is why he created
only ten sisters instead of 25 to make
it more realistic
then he redesigned some of his rabbit
characters and turned them into young
boys and girls this is how everything
fell into place but there are still some
rabbit traits left in the designs this
is the reason why Lincoln has a white
hair and why some characters have buck
teeth we are really happy to see that
Chris changed his mind because the loud
family is now much more relatable but no
matter what the creator loves to make
fun of his weird original idea if he
didn't listen to dinner he wouldn't be
where he is today the adoption with a
lot of fans come a lot of fan theories
and one of the most popular is that
Lincoln was adopted so allows parents
always wanted a son but they always had
daughters this is why they kept trying
over and over again one day they realize
that the only way they can have a son
would be by adopting him and this is how
Lincoln became part of the family that
would explain why this character doesn't
look like any of his sisters most of
them have blond or brown hair except
Lucy who probably died it yes Lincoln
might look like pop-pop but his hair
turned to white from age moreover in the
ties that bind the mother said that she
had ten kids not eleven meaning that she
probably didn't give birth to one of
them the father then replied he should
throw out the white one because he
didn't think that it was his we finally
found out that he was talking about ties
but it could still be a hint that
Lincoln wasn't always part of the family
some people also argue that Lucy is
actually the one who was adopted because
she looks really different than her
other siblings with her black hair pale
skin and personality no matter what we
think that we shouldn't ask too many
questions and just enjoy the show like
it is no matter who is adopted they are
still part of the loud family the names
it seems like the loud parent wanted to
make sure they remember the name of
their ten daughters because they all
start with the letter L and have four
letters Lincoln is the only exception
with seven letters in his name but where
does this idea come from
you'll be surprised to know that Chris
was inspired by his own life when they
were rabbits all the names started with
the letter B because the creator thought
that it had many female sounding names
when he narrowed it down to ten sisters
he remembered that his own sisters names
all start with the letter
Ehle and have four letters this is where
the names Laurie Lisa Lynn Luanne and
Lana came from yes Chris had that many
sisters but he is still missing six
names this was when he thought about
other four letter L names that he always
knew his weiner dog was named Lola and
his mother-in-law's dog was named Luna
Lilly and Lucy or two names as he and
his wife thought about when they wanted
a baby then Lenny was based on the
character Lenny from Of Mice and Men and
he just changed the spelling to make it
more girly the only thing missing was
the name of the boy this one was
actually inspired by the name of the
street his family used to live on and if
you were ever wondering know their names
don't make the personalities of the
characters the script many people have
been wondering if the sitcom was
scripted or not after all some voice
actors like to improvise and that's what
makes some TV shows really fun but this
time the loud house is mostly scripted
with a little bit of freedom the problem
is that if they knew that the story
focused on two characters storyboard
artists would only focus on these two
and forget about the other nine
characters in the household this is why
the creators had to write a script they
wanted to make sure that all the
characters were present in the show and
to give them equal screen time and
they're equal say and equal existence in
every episode they needed the show to be
scripted however even if they write 95%
of the script there is still a tiny room
for the artist to discover new things
for example they can see that the
characters standing here and it would be
fun to see how they react they also have
to fill in the holes and make things
funnier sometimes this is why the
storyboard artists have the freedom to
embellish the script a little bit so
don't think that it's easy to be funny
maybe people are actually working really
hard to make sure that every word is the
best
and so you'll laugh at every punchline
not a lot of shows have the power to
make us laugh as much as the loud house
the down syndrome
we know that the characters of the loud
house love the show diversity on screen
but it's not only about who you love
it's also about who you are in the
loudest mission relative chaos the
sitcom introduced a minor character
named Carlos jr. who has Down syndrome
even though he was in his teen years
TJ loved to play children's games and
easily befriend any person no matter how
childish she was we think that it just
made him a funny and lovable character
most people didn't understand why he was
acting
that weird and how we realized that he
actually had Down syndrome and that's
how we learned to better understand him
even though he was different some people
criticize that the creators made a
disabled character look stupid but
that's not what they intended at all
they just wanted a different character
to have a chance to appear on television
Chris Savino said that the whole notion
of having a character with a disability
came up because they knew it's not the
disability that makes the character he
knew someone with Down syndrome growing
up in his neighborhood and he wanted to
make sure that he was represented
because he was there in his life and we
think that Chris actually had a great
idea the only thing missing is that we
wish that we could see Carlos more often
in the following episodes the newspaper
comics before working on animated series
Chris Savino used to love newspaper
comics when he was young he used to draw
the eyes the noses and the other traits
of the characters he saw and mixed them
together to create his own characters
that was the thing he wanted to do have
his own comic strip he didn't even
realize he could do this job and that
there were even schools that would teach
him how to do that so he just worked on
his own now that Chris is working on his
own TV show he is still reading comics
but he knows that he probably won't be
selling one the loud house is kind of a
love letter to comic strips for example
the story has focused on characters and
the camera doesn't move a lot as you can
see it in comics as he said himself it's
become kind of a mantra on the show the
camera is not funny
the characters are funny this is also
what makes it easier to animate the 11
siblings because they don't have to use
too many camera angles moreover you can
see the comics aesthetic and a limited
color palette and the texture of the
backgrounds they yellows the paper to
make it seem like a really old comic and
this warmed up the scenes and tied the
colors together in a way that the
creator's didn't expect and this is how
Savino created this unique style the
transgender girl we read about other fan
series and this is probably one of the
weirdest ones that we ever heard some
people think that one of the girls was
actually born a boy can you guess who it
is it's Lynn and fans have many reasons
to believe that she is transgender
the name Lynn is unisex so she wouldn't
even have to change it if she wanted to
identify herself as a woman she was
named after her father Lynn's
but isn't it kind of weird for a girl to
be Lin junior moreover she acts more
like a boy than any of her sisters she
is more into sports than anyone we've
ever seen and she's also more
competitive she also didn't hit puberty
yet which could mean that she might be
on puberty blockers to look like a girl
for as long as she can and her
hand-me-downs Lincoln with a jockstrap
which is actually worn by boys we have
to admit with all this evidence this
theory could make sense after all the
creators of the loud house always
supported the LGBT community so it
wouldn't be too surprising for one of
the girls to be born male but no matter
what it will stay at theory until the
creators of the show themselves say it's
true and if Lynn wants to be a woman we
will treat her like the young woman she
is the inspiration we already know that
Chris Savino is born in a big family so
it's not surprising to learn that his
siblings inspired him when writing the
loud house the creator of the show had
four brothers and five sisters making
them ten kids in total however he didn't
realize the connection when he was
working on the family of rabbits it's
not until he turned them into humans and
created ten sisters that he understood
that he was inspired by his own big
family but the loud house isn't
autobiographical
it's just that many of his ideas come
from experience and he is not the only
one the other writers and artists
working on the project also had siblings
and talks about things that happened to
them when they were kids we might think
that Chris's brothers and sisters didn't
like to see themselves in the sitcom but
not at all they were actually really
proud of their sibling and were
flattered that their names were
synonymous with the cartoon now anyway
Chris said that he never really pulled
from anything that they have done and
applied it directly to a sibling they
all have a sense of humor and they can
laugh at everything so they are not
taking anything personally we think that
this is what makes the savino family
even better than the one we see on
television humor is the best thing to
keep a family together
the secret crush we know the creator's
at the loud house support the LGBT
community and Clyde's fathers are not
the only ones who are a little different
when it comes to love we found out that
one of the siblings is into girls
- and it's Luna as we could see it in L
is for love in this episode we saw her
giving a love letter to a girl named Sam
you might think that she's a lesbian but
that would probably make her bisexual
pansexual or queer as she had a crush on
a boy
another episode and no matter who she's
dating we think that all that matters is
that Luna is happy Chris Savino even
said that we would see Sam again in
another episode
unfortunately the group of 1 Million
Moms was once again upset by this topic
they didn't like this show because
families tuning in to watch its
children's network may encounter a
premature discussion on sexual
orientation which they considered
unnecessary they don't think that
Nickelodeon should talk about
controversial topics but what do you
think should we show more diversity on
television to let kids learn about the
LGBT community in a positive way or do
you think that it's inappropriate for
children to watch this don't be shy to
tell us what you think in the comment
section down below we'd love to know
what you think and that's it for ten
dark secrets in the loud house
Nickelodeon tried to hide for more
stories like this make sure you watch 10
mistakes in the loud house you might
have missed thanks for watching
[Music]